Now unless you're one of the first students to make it
through this class there are probably a lot of, responses in that
thread. And in this question you're really going to take advantage
of the form. And the way your going to do that, well, let's
write it as a flow. First your going to find somebody elses
response to the previous question. But when you do this make sure
that you don't read the review or anything but the name
of the app to begin with. Because the second step is to
form your own opinion about this app. What do
you like about it? What do you dislike? What would
you change? Once you figure these answers out for yourself,
you can go on to step three, which is actually
to take a look at the other students' prezi. You'll
learn what they didn't like about this particular app and
how they would fix it. Finally, you'll respond. Just in
that same thread, you'll respond to the post that this
other student has made. And this is the part where you have to make sure to be
productive. Nobody's wrong in these situations, different people like
different things. In fact, in the next lesson, we're
going to learn that even though good or good
can differ between users. We still have systems and
techniques that we can use to insure the products
we build will be good for our intended audience.